this may not be as crazy as we think so
give us some kind of historical context
as to how you know kind of different is
right now versus that the past time to
the stock market so like most investors
the best thing you can do as a young
person is to lose all your money and so
I did that many times early in my career
discretionary trading and that's what
moved me more and more towards quant by
the way and so you know running out that
management business now but the
foundation for this was I said look I
have all the behavioral biases I'm
overconfident
I'll take too much risk if you give me
so I really need to understand and have
some expectations to which to set an
anchor to ground myself so to be an
investor you simply have to be a student
of history and so my favorite investing
book trap the optimist you can go back
over a hundred years investment returns
really you can go back to Amsterdam
Stock Exchange and 1600 but really
modern era there's about two hundred
years but if you look at today and
what's going on this feels weird to say
to a lot of people particularly younger
people but this is all pretty normal and
the reason being is that stock market
normal stock market returns are extreme
and let me elaborate on that we wrote a
paper a number of years ago called where
the black swans hide and it demonstrated
that down 5% days are totally normal
as our up 5% days right this is the
tails of the distribution they happen
about 1% of the time even down 10% days
totally normal
they have a point 1 percent of time and
this is in all the countries around the
world and then even bigger down days can
happen of course you know and in October
87 we head down 20 and plenty of markets
around the world
I think today is some are down 15 20 %
alone but the funny thing is is people
don't expect that so is you came into
this year for example all the Wall
Street strategists I did this in a tweet
they said what he expects shock returns
for next year and they clustered in
between minus three and ten percent but
he look at the historical yearly returns
it's like you
80% of the returns fall out of that
range yes that's the average but normal
returns are extreme look last year we're
up thirty right this year down thirty or
wherever we are today but that's pretty
normal now that having been said you
traditionally see volatility cluster
meaning as you've seen in the last month
these huge up and down days and we did
this study and we show that most of
these big down and up days occur after
the market is already declining so you
could use something like the 200-day
moving average and say why though just
like around two-thirds or seventy
percent of these big up-and-down day as
a curve in the markets declining well if
you think about it and it makes a lot of
sense that it's because people are
emotional right markets are going down
they use a different part of their brain
when they're making money but think back
to last year people probably checking
their account balance every day on
Robinhood they're thinking about buying
a new house they're hiding themselves on
the back for how smart they were and
then look at that stock I bought their
bracketing at their neighbor they're
opening the console segments all that
stuff right in the very real visceral
physical experience of making money it
stimulates a lot of the same parts of
the brain as many pharmaceuticals would
or drugs would on the flip side when
you're losing money it's a very real
visceral physical experience it's
painful you don't want to open your
account balance you don't want to talk
to your neighbors that guy is such an
idiot for recommending that security to
me I can't believe I listen to his
advice that's so stupid
and at some point you start to panic and
say I can't take anymore I got to get
out look we're only down on the stock
market I don't know it's called today
30% and had you not studied history you
wouldn't have realized that look we had
250 percent in the last decade about to
2000 we go back far enough you remember
the Great Depression that was over 80
and in plenty of stock markets around
the world you've had worse and in couple
stock markets Russia in 1917 and China
in 1949 and they said no thank you very
much we're closing it the government's
taking all of your assets no more
private businesses and that's had to do
with communism but
um you had to know at least what was
possible we did a tweet last night where
and this goes along with a another
article we did on expectations and we
said by the way this is a fact who
interpreted as you want but long bonds
when one of the most universal beliefs
in the entire world of investing is it
stocks outperform bonds 99 probably
percent of people believe that as a
fundamental truth but the problem is
most people don't believe that stocks
can go long periods of underperforming
bonds and right now as of today stocks
have gone 40 years underperforming bonds
how'd you study history you would have
known that you would have known there's
been periods of 20 years a couple times
in the 19th century you say that's too
long ago there's pick a period of 68
years so the challenge with that is most
people think in terms of days hours
weeks quarters and certainly not years
and that mismatch of truly setting
expectations and what works on a long
period and actually implementing it
causes a lot of problems and as your
partner said I said this on Twitter the
other day at Mark usko one of my
favorite quotes is investing is the only
business when things go on sale everyone
runs out of the store and that's the
beauty of the quant approach and having
a plan and we can talk more about that
but if you don't and let the emotions
work their way in that's where you start
to see fractures and problems happen
yeah it's so funny one of the first
things he ever said to me is humans are
really good at doing two things one is
they always buy what they should have
bought and they always sell what they're
about to need right which is kind of the
same thing around when when the prices
go down everyone runs away but I think
that the book that you mentioned kind of
about this optimism right especially
what you're saying here is if you
believe that it's not going to go to
zero right these dips and kind of drops
in the prices are actually opportunities
right and again as long as it doesn't go
to zero they end up having high
volatility days or over long periods of
time you get kind of a continued
increase in value across the different
stock markets
but that's the difference between a my
you know being emotional today versus
some long period of time actual having a
plan being disciplined kind of in
control my emotions etc let me go to let
me give you a good example from the book
and so it looks at like thirty forty
different stock markets back to nineteen
hundred and there's so much information
but it gives you a great base case so if
you look back historically stocks have
done around let's call it nine percent a
year and then after inflation down
around five globally okay bought and so
if you call inflation four percent
during that period bonds historically
did around six after inflation two bills
around five after inflation one so I
call it the five to one rule
so after inflation your expectations be
that stocks return five bonds return two
bills perform one one of the key parts
about this study is that it's really
important to diversify because again you
go back to nineteen eighteen ninety nine
we're sipping champagne we're having
this discussion in London or New York or
wherever maybe it wasn't altogether
clear that the US was gonna dominate the
twentieth century you had a scenario
where than in 1900 by the way the vast
majority of US stock market was
railroads okay but also the US was
wasn't the largest market cap country UK
was us was only about fifteen percent
they ended the decade around half the
century around half so massive outlier
on the upside now they weren't the best
performing stock market I think tiny
South Africa was but there were other
ones ignoring the ones that bureau i had
essentially zero return austria and
others and if you flip the equation you
look at the bonds same thing some bond
markets be great some went to zero
usually because of hyperinflation and
world wars etc but the beauty of this is
if you take a long view and this we
wrote a book about this called global
asset allocation and we said look
there's all sorts of investors out there
super famous investors like dave Swenson
from Yale Rob or nod from research
affiliates Warren Buffett Mohamed
el-erian
that all at some point have said here's
a recommended asset allocation okay
and we in this book we said okay let's
see as a quant let's see how these have
done in history and so we took all the
main ingredients so if you're taking all
the ingredients off the shelf you got
global stocks global bonds global real
assets like real estate and commodities
gold and we said let's look and see how
these portfolios performed in we took
them back all in 1972 we're gonna take
this back in 1920s we've already done it
but hopefully update that this year and
there's some interesting takeaways first
of all is that all the portfolios did
great but they were hugely different
so some portfolio said you should have
nothing in gold others said 25% some
said 90% in stocks some said 25% so
there's these massive differences right
but in reality it turned out it didn't
matter all that much let me give you a
good example so if you go back to 1972
and I said pump I'm gonna give you a
crystal ball I'm gonna let you pick the
single best performing asset allocation
model from this book and I'm gonna let
you implement it from 1972 to 2018 2019
2020 whatever how much would someone pay
for that in the billions probably pemko
and it is fidelity Schwab would pay
billion stars to have this perfect
foresight into what works the best and I
said however you have to implement this
with the average mutual fund fee of
today which is one point two five
percent forget going back to 1972 index
funds didn't really exist but the
average mutual fund then and you say
okay well walking forward if you look at
the best performing asset allocation
implementing it with perfect foresight
but with those fees transfer forms the
best performing asset allocation to
almost as bad as the worst rendering the
entire asset allocation decision almost
meaningless so if you're doing the just
basics the what I like to call asset
allocation for dummies your specifics
don't matter that much as long as you
have some global stocks some global
bonds and some global real assets and I
liken this to to baking in my mom's from
North Carolina she doesn't ever use
cookbooks she does it by feel this much
butter this much
if you exclude whole categories of
ingredients it's probably not gonna work
to put all your money and gold probably
not gonna work but in general if you
have the main ingredients it it works
out just fine and so people obsess so
much about gosh do I have too much in BA
I have too much in stocks what do I do
this or this and in general as long as
you have the basics covered it doesn't
really matter as long as you don't
implement it very fluently and most
important do the really dumb thing which
is make really dumb behavioral mistakes
you know and panic at the bottom sell
the top over and over we see so many
examples of this today we'll get updates
they do this every week my favorite
example of rationality is the American
Association of individual investors they
do a weekly survey goes back to the 80s
they say are you bullish neutral or
bearish on the stock market and the most
bullish reading ever was in December of
1999 the single worst time to be bullish
in the hippy of our lifetimes and the
most bearish people were it was in March
of 2009 again the sync you could not
make this up this is not some academic
you know hypothetical this is the real
world and today it's probably gonna
print something really low we'll see but
historically if you sort based on those
those extreme readings it's usually a
really good time so that sets the case
for the expectations of the base case
and why is that important
because we did this piece recent online
a four part series recently about what's
going on in the world there's like time
to panic and there was a three part
series called the get rich portfolio
stay rich portfolio how I invest my
money and investing in her time of
Corona and the first part about the get
rich portfolio was that if you put money
to work I hope there's 20 year-olds
listening this podcast because this is
fantastic opportunity you put money to
work right now you get 10% returns just
for math say 25 years you 10x your money
50 years you 100 extra money you do not
have to do anything it takes zero effort
we talk so much about this on the
podcast and the blog this is the beauty
of capitalism and free markets is you
can take a little bit of sweat of your
labor put it into other people's labor
and
magically transform that into multiples
of money in future decades so the
decision by far that plumps everything
else is when you decide to start
investing how much how much you save and
how much you invest and so the basics
and again we can talk more about a lot
more timely and tactical implementations
and tilts and everything else but this
is this is something anyone on the
planet can do and do it for no cost
essentially today and have phenomenal
returns the hard part of course is is
avoiding those emotions which try to
lead us astray